now in its sixth season HBO's hit comedy
beep have you seen it looks at the
fallout from Selina Meyers losses the
presidency actor Reed Scott plays former
political aide Dan Egan he's now one of
the hosts of the fictitious CBS this
morning he calls on his political
contacts to build his reputation on TV
and when the approval of his how should
we call her prickly co-host the
borough's our name and our graphics
spot-on I've got to ask what we're all
thinking
the White House hmm so you're definitely
not gonna run again in three years I
have no plans to run at this time you're
a hand
welcome back to CBS this morning joining
me now is freshman congressman Jonah
Ryan of New Hampshire who recently had a
close shave with cancer don't miss
brookheimer and I did have a brief
relationship when she was a much younger
woman you did thank you to you both
we'll be right back okay you like Jane I
could throw your name out there for you
do you think I'd make a good judge you
do like throwing books at people so
until tomorrow I'm Jane the cave and I'm
Danny see you in the tomorrow and we're
clear
today's do me a favor sure wrap the wire
around my neck until I did read Scott
welcome to the real CBS this morning I
love this show this is a real listen we
were all feeling so flattered that you
guys chose CBS to do the show but it
really sort of happened by mistake did
it not a little bit yeah it was it was a
joke from last season where Dan my
character sleeps with Amy's sister
because when she tells him that she
works at CVS pharmacy he thinks she's
saying CBS and then you said can you get
me a job there oh yeah sure you know if
you're willing to you know to work
nights he's like oh my god the the
late-night you know death shift sure you
play such a jerk read thank you I mean
I'm using the word jerk because I really
want to use a word but we can't you play
such a jerk
what made people think you would be such
a good character for that how'd that
happen
well my my friend Jen Houston who's a
casting director here in New York she
was handling the show and she called me
up seven years ago now and she said look
I got this great part it's opposite
Julia Louie Dreyfus but it's tricky
because he's a jerk but he needs to be
likable and read you're the most likable
jerk that I know but she didn't use the
word jerk now she didn't use the word
judge yeah so what is it what any
research you did to prepare for your
anchor persona I did a little bit you
know one of the unique things about our
show is that it's not it's not a rip
from the headline show if not
necessarily no one's supposed to be
anyone necessarily so I wanted to get
familiar but I didn't want to really you
know copy anybody or ape anybody so you
watched our show oh yeah oh yeah and I
was surprised but I walked in day one of
shooting and the set was I mean it's
it's remarkable artist that's a credible
job graphics everything everything this
is a satire is it it might be a
documentary it might be it's a comedy
yes in terms of what are you trying to
say about morning television oh man well
you know one of the fun things that we
discussed in the early days of veep is
that it's a workplace comedy really
could be sort of any industry and it was
just sort of taking you know making
light there was meratol indoors exactly
yeah and now we've got to the point and
it's kind of funny how we've sort of
stayed away from it until now
there's so many things to say I mean the
the the obvious connection between
politics and the world of broadcast
journalism we've never really there was
also very good I want HBO call newsroom
oh yeah well I love that too but you
know what's interesting about your show
is the Democrats think you're talking
about them the Republicans think you're
talking about them that's right has that
been your experience when you go out in
the world and you meet people what do
they say to you it's really strange we
you know we all got invited to the White
House press Correspondents Dinner and
we've had incredible access over the
years to two people on the hill and
you know the real movers and shakers or
cameo roles they all want cameo roles we
don't give him out I remember the the
governor of Maryland really wanted us
the former governor of Maryland busy
with running president he was only a
president and I don't but he also wanted
to come on
I think they considered it he wanted to
come on and look cool this is gay men
look cool
no no she O'Malley yeah yeah they just
the people that we've met whenever we
meet a Republican they say I was so
refreshing to see a show go after those
Democrats the Democrat and I'll say keep
sticking it to the Republican you
remember a long time ago there was
laugh-in and Richard Nixon sure went on
and was laughed at oh yeah the idea by
Roger Roger Ailes was stalking her
mm-hmm I would love it I mean I think we
can we can soften our politicians up
even more but now that they're afraid of
us talk about the effort sort of to win
over your co-anchor Jane McCain mm-hmm
first of all Margaret :
who plays Jim because she's great okay I
know and it's no small feat to jump into
the show we have a really good process
for all just bizarre maniacs at this
point so she did a great job jumping in
uh it's been really fun because Dan is
he's a climber so yes and he's a bit of
a cat and a womanizer so I think he
looks at this is you know potential for
both one of his great lines is I haven't
slept with a woman over 30 since I was
14 and that's because I needed a great
he's a people he's a big guy he is but
the writing I think to read is so good
it seems so spontaneous and off-the-cuff
well it that sort of goes back you
rehearse a lot we do which is unusual
for a television show yeah from our
early days we were we would actually get
scripts sometimes four or five episodes
in advance which never happens in TV and
we would be sequestered in London our
original showrunner and our writers well
British would be there and we Hearst for
weeks at a time always encouraged to
improvise and the writers would then go
and rewrite the scripts with your brains
our improv exactly and so through the
sort of distillation process it gave you
this very natural feel it's been really
fun well it's really good fun to have
you here thank you very much
a mistake starting with CBS but it sure
it gives us such a kick to watch all
great you're fun to watch like I'm very
great thank you